and another thing
that trump might need containment for
is his recently announced january 6th
commemorative uh press conference that
he's going to be holding down in south
florida
this week trump did in fact announce
that he is going
to hold this big press conference give a
big ol speech
on the anniversary of the january 6th
capital riot
this is going to be held at mar-a-lago
all all of the major media outlets will
most likely be there which
i happen to think is a big mistake i
think the best way to handle
this upcoming speech
is to totally ignore it and pretend it
doesn't exist
don't give him the air time
absolutely
do not make him feel important that is
the best thing the media outlets could
do
and the reason they should do this is
because we already know what kind of
drivel he's going to be spewing at us
during this little press conference or
whatever it is you want to call it and
we know that because he basically gave
us his talking points in his
announcement here it is
why isn't the unselect committee of
highly partisan political hacks
investigating the cause of the january 6
protest which was the rigged
presidential election of 2020. i will be
having a news conference on january 6th
at mar-a-lago to discuss all of these
points and more
until then remember the insurrection
took place on november 3rd it was the
completely unarmed protest of the rigged
election
that took place on january 6th
all right
so we're gonna hear some more election
lies
maybe he's got some new ones to throw
out there i don't know
you know it'd be great to have a remix
of the greatest hits instead of him just
going out there and playing the same old
songs that we all know so well
but the downplaying
of the events that took place on january
6th that's the real problem
and of course he's doing that i believe
because he's gearing up for a
presidential run and he wants these
people back in his corner
and he may have already lost some of
them because we have had plenty of
reports over the past year they're mad
they didn't get presidential pardons
they're mad he's not helping pay their
legal bills they're mad that he hasn't
stuck up for them more over this past
year so this might be his way of trying
to atone for that although with regards
to presidential pardons you really
missed your opportunity on that one
buddy
so i don't know how many of these people
are willing to come back to you i know
most of them likely will but some of
them clearly won't
but the danger
lies in what he's going to say
because he's going to as he tells us
here
try to claim that these people were just
peaceful protesters they weren't armed
they didn't deserve any of this of
course you can bet we're going to hear
stuff about ashley babbitt
and how she was murdered by police
officers and
how these bloodthirsty cops just shot
her in cold blood and for the record i i
do not think that ashley babbitt should
have been killed absolutely not
yeah it doesn't matter who the cops are
killing i'm against it
so i do think
that ashley babbitt should still be
alive today
so too
for the record
should the police officers that were
there
because that's the part these
conservatives always like to gloss over
they like to talk about ashley babbitt
but we got multiple cops
where's their concern for them where's
the blue lives matter crowd on that
issue
right
nowhere to be found radio silence from
those individuals
and one of the reasons i also believe
that donald trump is doing this
is because he sees the walls closing in
over here with that select committee
investigation or as he hilariously
called it the unselect committee who
burn
no that that's that's childish i could
take that to my seven-year-old and i
promise you he could come back in five
minutes with ten better insults for the
committee
if he wanted to go that route
but
the committee's getting closer
the committee is getting closer to
donald trump
the sentences that we're starting to see
handed down for these capital rioters
are getting longer they're getting more
intense
the judges this past summer we're
telling prosecutors you're being too
lenient on these individuals you're
letting them off for lesser charges we
can get them on more and we should to
prove a point
but most importantly trump knows that
that committee is getting closer to him
personally
so
he feels the best path forward for him
is to go out there with this press
conference that again the media should
ignore but they won't
he's going to go out there he's going to
lie about what happened he's going to
downplay it he's going to attempt to
rewrite history a year after we all
watched it unfold on our tvs
but he's not doing it to protect the
rioters
he's not doing it because he feels any
kind of sympathy towards these
individuals
he's doing it
to make it seem like a lesser offense
that his office at least
was attempting to overturn the results
of the 2020 election
and of course that's why we're going to
get mostly election lies out of him that
day
you know he has kind of been
amped up about all of that recently
and it is because his administration is
being exposed we're finding out things
because of the select committee
that we likely would have not otherwise
known we would not have known about the
text messages with mark meadows
we would not have known about the fox
news host reaching out and panicking oh
my god you got to do something about
these people
so all of that combined
has culminated in donald trump feeling
the need to go out there and rewrite
history for all of us and again not just
the history of january 6th but the
history of the 2020 election
we've had the audits we've had the
recounts we've had the signature
verifications we have gone through every
possible step of the process
and the fraud that we have found
almost all of it
rests in the hands of republican voters
still majority of republicans believe
the 2020 election was in fact stolen
so trump will never give up those
talking points
because unfortunately
they've been pretty darn effective with
his republican base
i'm faring cousins and for david pakman
we'll be right back
one of our sponsors is self-decode
self-decode is a genetic testing and
analysis platform that gives you tools
to gain insights about your health based
on your dna this is a new technology
we're still learning so much about
what of substantive value can we get
from these types of results but by using
artificial intelligence and machine
learning you can get personalized
insights based on your specific dna as
well as getting lab test analysis and
recommendations really a lot of
interesting ways to get information
about yourself through the self-decode
platform they never sell your
information they never give away your
information to anybody self-decode sent
me a dna kit to get my saliva i did the
test sent it back and in just a few
weeks i had my results i found for
example that genetically i'm not at big
risk for kidney stones
not at big risk for asthma
unfortunately i'm at slightly increased
risk of headaches which is true which is
true and the recommendations you get are
really simple and logical things
relating to sleep relaxation etc very
very interesting and this is a
technology that's going to develop and
mature significantly over the next five
to 10 years self-decode is giving my
audience 25 off when you click the link
below and use the coupon code pacman